yeah hello and welcome to this broadcast
I hope you all find a couple of guys in
the shed already I'm a bit late but yeah
I couldn't could do much about it I had
to finish finishing a lesson properly
and after that needed to do one or two
things that were really urgent so let's
get let's get going here and let's play
some 5-minute games of course and I
completely completely wrecked my rating
last week that last Monday but I have to
say that I got it back as it tends to
happen I got back yeah hello to all of
the regulars in started that's really
loud let's turn this down a little bit
yeah hello to all the regulars in the
chat like meat grinder or Biggus Dickus
Oh Tony Raquel azan hi Tony
so welcome to the show tony is the
author of a chess book killer Sicilian
so M poco poco a poco place the semi
sloth type of set up against my opening
yeah this is a very decent way of
playing I think why it is just a little
bit better him but it's not not much so
I'm happy about the isolated pawn but
the thing is he has some counterplay the
dark squares in particular
okay so Quinta a 5 it's not playing so
quickly ok I go here for Queen B to
potentially
no that's not an equalising line I mean
black I think they're still on suffice a
little bit hem just a little bit I mean
I still rather be YTM many and many
endings white can still press a little
bit yeah
I don't like to trade heavy pieces here
all that much but it's tough too it's
tough to get the upper hand on the
seafoam okay I think I'll trade
not bad
so maybe click a three here try to
provoke the book trade and I'm
threatening now to take and win the poor
95 so I think it will very likely just
take one see one I can pray and play a
premium of them yeah yeah this is not
much but white is still having a slide
pool and disposition okay so queen-to-be
2 is the normal move I don't want to
allow well-acquainted be to actually
does allow Queen you won so this is a
bit of an annoyance and it's not quite
clear what to do my head accounts
repertoire that's in the works will
still take a long time so it is
completed
I really think yeah very weeks months
maybe it I don't have much time for side
projects okay so Queen a5 um
there's potentially here Queen e1 and a2
are saying so I probably play the pawn
you want you would rather be black here
no that is a wrong assessment I mean
it's probably equal
but I mean black black is definitely not
for choice him okay so I'm going to
approach with the king
so if I go kingly tool you will play
night before I wonder if f3 is actually
an idea it looks a little bit strange
but it is an interesting move actually
kingly to was also blundering you
tonight b1 no I'm not a big fan of
asparagus that's a funny question by
rusty cheap asparagus is spotted by the
Schweitzer father okay so we had gotten
into a pure Bishop ending why I'm
slightly better very slightly but I am
slightly better so is there any way for
me to make any headway in this position
probably not how can we do it
I effect I can try something here put
the bishop here and actually this is
something that I recently saw in a game
while putting the pawns on light squares
which looks strange but it is a way to
make some headway and two months old
asked if I am stronger over the border
online if there is a difference and that
certainly depends um I mean online I
don't play any longer time control games
quite clearly morning I know that looks
weird but I have an idea with this
yeah he saw the right way to play this
you have to put it down yeah I don't
have I don't have anything yeah yeah
exactly
Tony you you got it right it is going to
Cleveland you know your stuff
yes okay so there is nothing to move it
draw a third game drawn
yeah the other ideas if the bishop is
like here on f7 and I have F or if the
bishop if you would have put the bishop
here like on g8 f 7-9 you know the
justice I'm just showing that idea and
by playing some some moves that glory
don't make sense here like in this
situation I have before before this is
an idea and if the bishop is on that
debt again that diagonal it would work
yeah but even then you have to fight you
have to do to win actually hit because
you don't even win some of the bidders
of the camp Oh Lennox yeah there was a
difference so okay new game and see what
happens
the gingy Indian is it a good opening
other depends if white actually allows
this Bishop takes the free stuff with
this Kuja wide usually actually avoids
this nowadays this is okay for black
this is okay for blacks game good while
usually avoids it anyway so um
four against who is rst we don't know
but you can try to refute pelicans and
and yeah people get caught cheating
online I don't know how the it's a
difficult in this is not something which
has some some kind of I guess a real
legal background I mean an apology is
definitely not enough people have to be
banned for this kind of behavior and I
personally um I mean I would would Bend
them quite heavily because it's just the
lowest of the low where to to cheat in
online chess um okay so here Queen c7 on
let's go Queen c7 requesting a Dutch
defense okay so I can try g6 and snatch
this one I think he wants to actually
play Bishop g2 go f4 maybe
and for I have a check here so yes this
is really okay and now h v
and I wonder if he has f5 and that
really makes some sense
92 e4 is also an idea
really tempted by HR let's do it I mean
ff5 is very scary but he didn't do it
yes so he's not threatening to take that
is not threatening to take and he's also
not threatening to take to pledge you
form okay yeah he wants to play B for a
for stuff okay I have to this is
something where time is critical so
let's see if I can open the solve
yeah do I go here I think I do
and very tough on you see if you're
threatening 85 maybe I mean it is
Diddy's yeah okay maybe I don't have the
time
yeah with some of those cheating cases
it's a bit difficult yeah there was the
mention of a over over over German
player who who was heavily suspected of
cheating but there was never any
official yeah it was never an official
thing where people where it could be
proved and this is a difficult difficult
difficult difficult case I would like to
comment on it more but you know this
game is kind of tough if it's extremely
sharp here this position
rook-a for maybe group a for C fourth
super superstar yeah each one
h4 probably is the move and now 993 I
guess and then take or take immediately
I take immediately there is 96 and I'm
not sure what I'm doing them time
warning quintic c3 is an extremely
extremely cool okay it's probably better
so here
yeah probably this not waste any time
take there with the Queen and then my
time
oops takes with the rook rook c4 is an
idea no I have 95 I would probably you
can still play it and I'm too much I
mean in too much pins here probably
oh good game here I guess Baris team
probably okay for something like that
yeah okay and may that I was a strong
game by white I guess that was a strong
game I don't know maybe I had something
good but I don't know it was super tough
tough to evaluate I think at the
beginning the district okay but it was
sharper than sharp yeah okay so I'm okay
with losing such a game I mean you
really played well okay so in mortal
let's beat immortal and I really mean it
I want to be them I have a good score
against this person sorry
so mainline ready gambit and very early
g6 okay I don't quite remember the
details but this kind of position is
always slightly better forward
white has an extra center pawn and it's
not quite clear what black is doing
besides playing with his pieces now this
this usually doesn't lead to much I
always play that blue and white since I
play one line with it I don't like much
the the brown white and the contrast
I don't like getting some space on the
queenside you know I never really
understand what this is all about
because here wow really
that's terrible it's too T to be
terrible but also technically I'm okay
you can actually play 95 or 94
[Music]
yeah I think I'll insert that queen g4
is our play Bishop f3 the queen is
trapped right where's it going this is
really funny how the Queen has no square
black line sorry for for being all
giggly it was funny ok yeah I 1986 you
played in green green on the Schneider
CPC six six one two eight I didn't have
one of those but I know no them game
started so mr. Boris
give me your points just give me your
points I'm amazed how popular this line
it is so completely completely unarmed
Onias but people still have an affection
like that affection for it six is right
I remember that this is correct but I
don't remember any details yeah I don't
think it's actually rubbish and it just
um it is just difficult to claim for
white because yes its development is bad
and so on but it's so difficult it's so
difficult 95 it's just this huh what is
the point we should be 5 I just thinking
evade
okay yeah so where's the night going now
that I would like to know wow
I move like Queenie I don't really do
much we can take I mean if I just take
before I must be fine but I don't know
this is best okay let's do it
so this is an equal material position
where he has nothing I know nothing
developed but I have this weird king and
the King on evade Queen yet I didn't
like that was big fire them yeah this is
clear that the status is possible which
I didn't think this is all that elastic
I don't mind to get 2g aid when jeez yes
this is this attacked so I can just
think be tuned now or play Queen to be
eight which is also a good move take
this take edge tool but I would don't
want to play too lame in it in a two
lane way how to do it I can just grab
the pawn of course maybe this is
actually the way to do it
yeah chicken yes to play the dim soul of
BOGO stuff I still do it I played them I
just studied the Bangko for this
repertoire while it was kind of i
studied the banco liked it made the
repertoire and now I'm kind of stuck
with it
it is also an extremely extremely good
opening in blitz chess they just you
have this active flame and that makes it
dumb makes it very nice for the quicker
time controls my idea is that at queen
be a difficult double attacking the
bishop n on h2 yeah motivation for
training I don't know
I uh I've always been motivated because
one thing I really learned over the
years is that chess is something where
hard work pays off enormous Lee it's not
like you do lots of things and you never
get anywhere if you ingest you get
somewhere so this one I'm not sure about
it
I'm trying to say that work pays off and
chairs absolutely I just go back in yeah
played the banker in the long-term
control game sure and in some games two
or three games I think it was okay I
mean I beat one or two weaker players
and I lost against the to 370 player but
that was not due to the opening the the
opening position was was really okay the
problem was more than I needed to win
this game and at some point I just took
her the risk was too too too high to
take and I am actually made a mistake
them but yeah was not difficult to to
spot better still I still failed them
and yeah this I didn't really think
about this move but it is not bad
[Music]
you
and levels bad him okay that was not
good not good at all because my
development sucks and it's not getting
any better time warning this is really
not so good that's not so good as could
dissolve this fantastic position
my background is very big a queen move
could be extremely tricky to meet 25 25
so to know 94 is not a threat because of
Queen III that's very lucky actually
you
check not grade
check growl offered game drawn no time
now I mean this is bad yeah I had a
completely winning position and then
sported to something problematic here
just peep like just completely winsome I
don't know I didn't I didn't do it then
probably probably already I shouldn't
take and play g16 g17 like that tough
game but interesting game sorry okay Wow
another strong opponent will impass I
think I played before axle-back man from
Paraguay this is actually the Paraguay
flag yeah it's tough to to make out into
okay let's see what he does against this
okay that's the most critical line of
course the acceptance of the sacrifice
would you be so nice
mr. Bachmann here and it has screws up I
don't know
you
so what to do
right over here
I think somewhere you have to go for the
question by Marcus I have no idea about
the trial accounts
how will they work and so on okay I
think I get in there
you
I have some serious pressure here night
before check coming check let's get the
next one in no I never play title choice
a Tuesday on chance calm the thing is I
always teach I always teach on Tuesday
evenings I never managed so he is kind
of falling apart there but the a porn is
dangerous with it quite clearly so now I
can can tape on b2 but I don't know what
this does
I mean how dangerous it is he's got a
six
this isn't all that clear I can actually
I can do this now I can check click a
six here I can also check here first
that is probably not so convincing check
if I check a ticket at six rook takes
Bishop C three days
Bishop to h6 but I can go back back here
hmm
yeah maybe that's stopped winning which
is a bit of a shame but it might be the
case that I just have a draw
check
ooop takes us Bishop h6 so we cannot
play that playing it a bit safe here I
think what he's doing is just not right
now he's trying to play for something
when there's nothing he is trying to
play for time but the position is not
good for watching it's not better at
same time warning
yeah I forgot that you can go back now
that's stupid that's a bit stupid check
check
you
and it was stupid to go into them to go
into this it of course it's just a draw
but is it a draw
you
you can do this first and cupid's are
come on this is crazy this is crazy what
I'm doing him I'm such a mom I'm such an
idiot
I forgot that you can take I was just
thinking about f5 yeah that is crazy
absolutely crazy Nestle and even what
what an idiot I am losing this game is
the worst I mean this is of course dead
and I can just click here that's a
better ending of course this is just
better for black come on and such a
[ __ ] sometimes idiotic I was just
thinking like f5 c + f5 and he calls he
doesn't play IX what a joke am losing
this game where white was playing for
lost a long time amazing ok so then I
have to be Queenie Fox of course I saw
the variation of course but I'd still
played h5 because I thought you will go
f5 me that's what does he play I mean
come on you're not serious you're right
what is this this is like this is a
King's Indian from hell you know with b6
funny
I don't know if there is an English
translation for Kuna facts I don't even
know what it would mean and in German so
um what is blacks plan here he wants to
just get killed on the queenside I guess
how do I do it
there should be three Keaney - probably
yeah this is the worst Kings Indian
defense ever that is probably about
right
I still not quite understand how a boost
the game before and that was just the
most idiotic thing ever this is the
Austrian flag so I've installed the
bishop here so but how to how to open
this up it's not so easy to get in
Knight B 3 and C 5 and he is completely
shut down this may be here to try to
take now we open this up and now I can
play with a 1 a 795
yeah this is not nice there bishop f8 so
how do we continue like this okay eight
deform it shouldn't really lead to
anything I'm threatening night to a
seven now
ninety-seven is the simple threat
now we get to the real questions
Philip Hoffman asked do you in more
elderly more or less money nowadays
compared to your previous job I mean
well hmm
I have some ideas that actually might
might get to might even get to a
situation that it will be not less
anymore but it's a it's a little bit
less I also have to know I mean I've
been working in a bank which which is
notoriously well-paid and what no 97 and
what just wants to allow the trade I am
happy about that
okay now like before I guess yeah so
I've got an ending now and this is the
this is the the one thing you want here
in this position total control in an
ending would like is passive so do you
want to I think I want to invade yeah
okay it looks good
yes by the schweitzer you extremely
right about that epithet banks pay
notoriously well and you're oftentimes
really wonder why okay I was thinking
might be three to six five we're just
taking us of course also fine
94 looks like a counter climate I take
is higher so it cannot really move the
night yeah this is a good question and
this working from home ever feels
isolated and you know it's really
important I think that when you work
from home that you have some things on
the agenda that you sometimes just leave
the house and do something else and I
mean you're sitting at home the whole
time sitting is wrong and you're doing
stuff but it's it sometimes it can be a
little bit a little bit yeah
you don't communicate all that much I
mean you talk to people of course but
okay it's um it's sometimes really and
what I miss is those sometimes those
simple talks like over coffee or
something li about some some trivial
things you know okay this is major
checkmate um okay so I managed to win
against Queen Hawks and gained my game
against your shake every single session
here we go your cheek it's always fun in
those games it's a complete technical
mess so we have a king's engine and we
get some get some mess yes some weird
thing here for any places stuff with a
six something like that
play the fire ovens you are not with
white probably never at all
sometimes they play with g4 in this
position I don't have to I don't know
this so well yeah this is a somewhat
uncommon move autumn
yeah thanks for twist twist cue it for
commenting on my ICC video series I
really enjoyed doing it so I'm happy
that you liked it so for canceling long
and I don't know it's a good idea to
castlelong what happens if I actually
just stay in the middle here and see
what he does it's not I mean f5 and this
stuff is not that easy to play him I
mean you can play it but I'm not getting
checkmated the king lonely one should be
funny at least complicated so here
[Music]
let's put into f2
technical mess incoming this is probably
true yeah Marcus you're right people are
talking more about improvement than
actually trying to do it
this is also my impression this is the
thing that they buy all kinds of books
and then all of a sudden they notice oh
my god I actually have to read them and
then it gets complicated it's so night
to be 5 was my idea
I needed to get away from the C file
because of taking and Bishop takes b5
their tough position areum I mean a7 is
hanging I don't know if he wants to
cover it
yeah I can try to play here here into a
form I usually I mean I don't think
ahead a day without chess for some time
I mean in the holidays by the amount of
vacation but normally I do some kind of
chance every day I'm not sure a queen
eighth form that doesn't really threaten
all that much now that I think of it
yeah I repertoire word is f1 chasuble is
in the works this is the other kinds
repertoire I don't know if I want to
take here twit decision but he has a he
cannot put a knight on c5 so a4 a5 looks
like it should works like it should work
okay but this side this should be fine
huh going to be six yeah I'm giving up
that corn it is that important really
Queen d7 I mean she check check yeah but
something I can play
I don't mind the porn now I'm better
definitely better him
you
chipton the key is this night the night
on detour
let's do this for night be three
I don't see how it keeps the April this
is how I keep seeing upon time warning
not good food there well offered you
know I'm so clearly better here the
problem is I have no time no no I'm not
taking a draw forget about it
I might have to draw at the end that's
it's possible but check he's a brilliant
swindler yes really
yeah yeah technical trick technical
trick and all of a sudden things get
difficult with yes time control check
check yeah yeah ah shoot no okay like
for fights on time yeah I was ashamed
I'm like got completely killed and then
he swindled himself out of it I can
never take the draw back is completely
out play anyway so one more game one
more game
yeah he relies on on on his tactical
yeah and trickery and I was a bit too
slow around here game started oh my way
has the final game so let's go for Ella
cons to keep place 93 now at four
Wow no idea so g5 I guess and that looks
ok F for black always they open have
found an issue might be maybe he
canceled the end and has 95 it could be
quite dangerous no I'm not a bit off
today I think I'm playing quite well I
just have the odds the audition and I
playing really strong opponents just in
case you I mean they were almost all the
with GM's
and I'm quite happy to just how play a
guy like your shaky I mean usually I am
I don't lose those but it happens
okay so checking is really really slow
it is a bill if that yeah that happened
when I screwed up when I screwed up at
the end of the Yoshi game hey hey I
think actually have to do it like that
spooky now it's okay
yeah I think I'm okay here even though
the general type of position is
certainly more of my ways Ellie is a
good technical player so we I wanted to
take with a night yeah now this one
filly like here it looks funny but
probably it's okay
I mean White's development is not all
that great so I don't think you can kill
me immediately
oops no 86-83 that's night b3 awesome
[Music]
and I've completely forgotten that I
have no really great square there okay
I mean 93 doesn't really make all that
much sense
he can't go before now that is actually
strong
I hear wide space advantage looks quite
frightening to be honest
but I was quick am i played quickly 95
might be a move there I just recognize
it but I can drop the Queen back I think
then b5 maybe I have to ship C 5 though
I just go back
yeah
you played file really my just six
minute of giving work here
ploop d6f Knight f5 maybe he just goes
92 so Knight f5 I think this is not easy
for white I've got two pawns already
threatening be five into these six
it's tough
it's not easy for me with no time time
warning I didn't want to give it out but
I probably have turn ok boy coming off
the Hammond okay well it was really a
tough time with this with this um with
this time situation so at the end of the
session I lost 10 points good game yes
but I'm still um I'm still happy with
with the session because I think the
games are all interesting and in general
I fared quite well thanks a lot for
watching
it's important for me to tell you that
I'm not going to be on next Monday
yeah next Monday I will not be on
because I'm on a pretty yeah vacation
yes because it's my birthday next
weekend I will be away a couple of days
to relax and so no show on next Monday
yeah make sure to take note of that
okay guys I hope you enjoyed the show
I'll be back in two weeks
thanks for watching